hey grammarians we we've talked about
prepositions of time and we've talked
about prepositions of space and i
couldn't come up with a cute name for
these because the the following five
prepositions are examples of what we
would call prepositions that have
connotations for neither time nor space
some of them do have time connotations
and some of them do have physical
connotations and what we're going to
talk about today however
are
the uses of these these words these
prepositions that don't have anything to
do with time or space they just have
they encode other relationships let's
get to it i'll show you what i mean
when we say about it can mean
you're talking about a specific subject
so i could say to you you know
tell me about yourself
the word by can be used to denote agency
or you know doingness
you'll see what i mean by that i mean we
can figure out who is responsible for
something uh with the use of the word by
the book was written by sudhir
so who did the thing sudeer did the
thing he's the the person with agency
he's the doer
the word for denotes use
so if you were to ask me for example uh
david what's a wood chipper used to do i
would say it's for chipping wood for
turning wood into chips its purpose
is chipping
of has this connotation of belonging or
being part of a place
so we can talk about the great green
dragon of inverness inverness is a place
it's in scotland
are there dragons there i don't know
i've never been
and with means
you know together or part of
there goes that snail with the painted
shell
you know which indicates that the the
snail and the shell are part and parcel
they're together so yeah so these
prepositions can be used for all sorts
of things i understand this can be
confusing
the prepositions are probably the most
complicated part of english and the
problem is you just need to memorize
them but the good thing is that there
aren't that many because as i've said
before prepositions are a closed group
we don't mint new ones so you don't have
to be
constantly trying to collect more ones
or pick them up or figure them out you
have a limited set that you need to
master and the way to do that is to read
and listen and talk a lot
you can do that you can learn anything
david out